The upshot of attacking and fixing the three sources of latency of concern for
real time task is that TS-Linux is able to provide quality of
service guarantees for real time applications
running on commodity operating systems such as
Linux. At the same time, by
admission control, using the proportional period scheduling,
TS-Linux ensures that throughput-oriented tasks are not
shut out from getting CPU time. The
proof of the pudding is in the eating. I encourage you to read the details
of performance evaluation carried out in this
paper that I've assigned to you for
reading, wherein the authors show that both
the above objectives are achieved by their design.